[Music]
in the West
faced with the growing pandemic most
epidemiologists favor the strict
lockdown and that was based on a key
study of the 1919 1920 Spanish flu
epidemic which showed that cities in the
United States that had enforced a very
strict lockdown did save lives but is
this study actually relevant to a new
virus with very different age groups at
risk could it be that that Spanish flu
of a century ago was helped by lockdown
because it hit all age groups including
the young well coded 19 of course is
much more damaging to older groups and
lockdown might even encourage more
contact with those who are at risk while
a fascinating and very very current
question which we'll be exploring
tonight
at how I gets in in a virtual sense of
course because of the coded 19 pandemic
let me introduce our speakers first
metric doctor who is a novelist and
professor of theoretical Abedini ology
at the University of Oxford she's
recently been in the news for her
criticism of the wide acceptance of
professor Niall Ferguson's Imperial
College groups paper which recommended a
strict lockdown to combat the corona
virus and then we have professor Hugh
Montgomery who is chair of intensive
medicine at University College London
and director of the UCL Institute for
human health and performance
he's also conducted research on Everest
he's run three up from marathons skydive
naked for charity and holds the world
record for playing piano underwater so I
think tonight's discussion should be
something of a breeze and then we have
select Spiegel halter the Winton
professor of the public understanding of
risk at the University of Cambridge with
David's background in medical statistics
he has recently become I think it's fair
to say one of the if not the UK's
leading voice in interpreting the data
of coronavirus my name is Rhonda Messer
I'm a presenter of BBC's free thinking
program on Radio 3 and the arts 90's
podcast and it's a real pleasure to be
hosting tonight so first of all we're
going to be asking each of our three
speakers to give us up to three minutes
of thought on the
of what does the risk of kovat really
mean the risk from kovat really mean and
I'm gonna turn first if I made to you
Ginetta what does the risk from Cove a
really mean what is the risk mean I
think that I mean obviously there is the
risk to the individual and the risk to
the society and one of the important
elements which you've already mentioned
that hasn't really come across it seems
to me in the debate concerning the
implementation of lockdown is who is
precisely is vulnerable both not both to
the disease itself and to the effects of
lockdown so I think in terms of risk
that there is a sort of somewhat
one-dimensional perception of risk which
is the risk of disease whereas in fact
what we should be weighing up are the
risks and the costs of most of the
processes the process of disease and the
process is not done impressively concise
thank you I I should say that the risk
from Co vid is the wider overarching
framework we've been given to talk about
the the debate but of course the
question of whether we should have gone
to knock down is very central central to
that so let me lead off from that if I
made to turn to our next speaker
professor Hugh Montgomery Hugh I mean
what do you see as important to that
question of assessing risk from kovat
and the question that Sinatra put to us
should we have gone into lockdown okay
so I think my personal views they are
entirely personal so what does the risk
of coronavirus needs me the first thing
is we need to differentiate risk and
hazard and I think the next speaker will
address that maybe much better than I
can but my experience of dealing with
medicine is that people are very very
poor at differentiating there is a to
think integrating them so dealing with
those we need to differentiate the risk
in the hazard but we also need to
differentiate those in terms of where
their direct are you whether that risk
or hazard is to me or whether it is by
my actions to someone else we need to
think whether those are immediate risks
so that perhaps whether I live or die
now whether they're delayed in other
words this
impacted economic changes we put in
place may damage us or others and indeed
whether those we saw there for personal
or societal and my comments that follow
are really colored by my experience in
the last nine weeks of a fair battering
it's fair to say of looking after
coronavirus patients in hospital and
intensive care and my experience of
health care in the last 36 years so
dealing lis the hazard first the hazard
let us not underestimate it is
absolutely catastrophic this disease is
unlike anything I've seen before it
isn't just a bit of pneumonia it isn't
getting a little bit of sort of oxygen
our patients have in careful itis brain
death stroke fits and seizures they have
muscle wasting they have lung disease
they have heart impacts they have liver
problems you have kidney failure and
half of the patients we put on intensive
care die and the other half are very
very badly battered and will take a long
long time through so the hazard here is
very substantial and that's not even
dealing with the moral impacts and the
emotional impacts to staff and indeed on
the families were often separated from
their loved ones real length great
length of time in terms of dealing with
the risk we are beginning to understand
what that risk might be but we're still
not certain of the data about quiet how
many people are infected to get honey
with symptoms but it looks from the best
time my understanding around 76 percent
of people who contract this disease will
have either no symptoms at all all
really very mild or limited symptoms
indeed so it's the 25% of the people who
get it all the 20% that become ill and
it seems that perhaps five to ten
percent of those go to hospital and
maybe one percent of cases or one in 120
will go to ITN half will die so the
personal risk across a population is
very small indeed
but the risk of course differs if
depending on the environment in which
you work whether you're poor which we've
heard a great deal of attacks and that
is definitely the case whether you're
male I am in a risk group whether you're
hypertensive diabetic of economies and
so forth so the risk is very much
greater for some others
um the next bit though is to think about
the risk to other people and this fate
business of the arm number in other
words how many people you infect if you
have it and we started off with an R of
around three to three point six abroad
and it's worth pointing out there called
that means this if I get it
and I give it to three others that's
four if they each give it to three
outlets that's thirteen by the time you
get to the tenth cycle um eighty-eight
thousand five hundred and seventy three
people have had the disease which means
that around two hundred and twenty
people will end up on an intensive care
unit so this business of us being
careful about transmission matters
because of those finally then the
question of how we mitigate those risks
and hazards well I suppose there was a
choice Wu Han could have locked down
aggressively at the very beginning so
that this thing was extinguished at
source and that's long gone that didn't
happen we could I suppose that a global
travel lock down almost immediately to
stop the disease spreading through the
air corridors and then had local lock
downs to try to extinguish the cases ie
my case identifying the cases and
locking them down but we didn't do that
either we could have let it run and we
could just accept that the majority
people get multimode rat disease that
there's a relatively small proportion
died from it so we just accept that hit
that could have been done well we could
have locked countries and brick by brick
extinguished the disease and then
reopened what we had seem to have done
is actually gone for a smouldering
approach to try to knock it down to
control the number of cases and then
lift the foot off the accelerator and
let that steady stream of cases come in
but let's be clear without herd immunity
caused by vaccinations or by long
lasting immunity which we don't know
what exists and the setting number of
people will contract this disease and
die so that's largely true there's some
we can mitigate that small number my
admission is an intensive care unit
so finally just in with the risk does
that approach and again our first
speaker can deal if I just don't bring
it to a conclusion here the risk the
risk then is the economic damage
this is savage and we know that 42% of
ill health in this country is
preventable and it's generally the poor
and those that have unequal distribution
of access to health care that are most
effective so there are risks the
approach that we've taken them so that's
where I shall stop
thanks very much anywhere you stopped it
just move we stop for the moment that
you'll be coming right back into the
discussion very very shortly but not
before we have turned to David Spiegel
holter David this question on risk and
how we should assess it really seems to
me at the heart of our discussion
tonight could I ask you to give us two
or three minutes on your thing this is
really complex and I'm supposed to be an
expert on risk communication and things
like this this is the most challenging
area I think I've ever had to deal with
and even what the terms mean you know
this the risk I think I like the
question the risk of coverage because
that means it's so ambiguous yeah as you
said to whom the risk to you or the risk
to society and as chanita said the is it
you know risks just in terms of dying
from kovin which is only one aspect of
this whole you know thing we're in at
the moment
and a way in which the benefits of
potential benefits and harms alternative
policies are very very complex to
continue watching this video click the
link in the top left or in the
description below or visit a IDOT TV for
more debates and talks from the world's
leading thinkers on today's biggest
ideas